si les mousquetaires était de retour et
la chasse parce que la chasse au
gascogne dans le petit d'artagnan est un
art et une grande tradition on prétend
que porto savez le plus solide appétit
un cochon entier ne lui faisait pas peur
alors si porto ce arrivé d'un coup
si vous apportez maintenant une pièce de
gîtes et maïté à nous maintenant qu'elle
nous fait eh bien on va commencer par
des poussées ce bond s'ennuyer alors à
nous deux à nous deux bon courage
on va le mettre en valais faire des
trous là pour le pendre à cette échelle
on va prendre un couteau de cuisine on
va lui faire des anneaux la la non ici à
cette pâte tout pareil où il tombe pas
celle qui l'a
on va le tirer un tout petit point mais
on a décroché moi je vais prendre cette
pâte
on va lui mettre deux crochets comme
ceux ci la l'autre patte est pour vous à
nous deux a noué poids lourd un peu trop
on y va ça y est vous est arrivé où il
n'avait votre mec très bien là et on va
traquer alors qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est
bon c'est bon
par quel bout est ce qu'on va attaquer
c'est tout un art et je vous conseille
sur jose assez singulière c'est tout
près là alors on va les faire et
d'entaillés le tour datent des passes
voilà je me passe là derrière la houlala
je passe là pareil ici de ce côté même
opération ressemble à quoi bon couteau
qui taillent une coupe a mené poil le
pauvre a pas tellement comment s'est pas
décidé c'est en général un travail
dormait ouais c'est qu'il faut
l'attraper l'acheminent maison que je
n'avais gageure gigot d'abord
pour d'épaisses été bien nourrie voilà
c'est bien nourris ce port s'ennuyer
j'ai gaspillé peu de fierté là et bien
là et nôtres sangliers voilà tout nu
enfin le décapiter maintenant on va y
arriver
c'est du pur elle fait ça comme un jeu
la yale et ben voilà la plus besoin pour
le mans là on va m'apporter on la
rejette
et puis maintenant lié aux forces à le
découper alors 1 2 3 on va le remettre
sur la table par veille et va ça va
c'est moins lourd qu'on croit loi eh
bien voyez il est beau en france on
l'appelle le morceau noble dans le
sanglier c'est au fond c'est gigolo
c'est la cuisson grande tradition de
manger un cuissot de sanglier et nous
allons vraiment pouvoir le manger de
rester car le warp et comment ce que
vous allez nous le préparer
on va d'abord et de couper dans l'autre
la prendre la choix ressortir ce couteau
qui est pointée par m voilà ensuite on
va le cuir à la broche celui là nous
allons regarder prendre un couteau plus
petit du jambon que voilà et nous allons
le garder c'est à dire faire des trous
et enfoncer les morceaux de jambon de da
zont en mettre partout
ce que vous appelez les morceaux de
journaux c'est pas de la montre est
c'est du vrai jambon de pays on met
d'ivresse jambon de pays 7,27 extra
aussi mais de la ventrèche aussi oui ça
on appelle ça la ventrèche rouler est
assaisonner sel poivre ail et ça donne
une bonne saveur
nous allons l'installer et le poivre et
sel en france et rossel membres
également ça je me rappelle bien comme
quoi vous croyez
swisscom 7 kg iii qui vers huy audi
n'est pas le voir lancer coûte cher que
trois doses au barreau est bien daté
pour que le sel rentre là bien me faire
reprendre par tous et apprendre à tenir
wavre des poires vous approchez il faut
bien le relever
alors maintenant à lens enfilez notre
broche là alors pendant que notre
cuisson cuit à la broche deux heures les
mardis nous allons tout ce temps pour
préparer autre chose
on va donc préparer la cible le civet on
va finir de découper si les bouchers me
regarde c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait
chez moi si j'avais moins singulier pour
m'apporter ci lui tende d'artagnan on
l'avait emporté assemblier fois bien se
débrouiller orient où ça et maïté ainsi
un chasseur dans la famille vous
apportant sangliers volant peut-être
qu'un boucher pour le faire ou bien se
débrouiller on se débrouille
après ne mèneront pas ici la dre d'avoir
une grossesse pas facile du tout et
voilà nous faisons la cuisine
quant à fait en famille ça y est c'est
fait
ta vérité cachée d'un vrai quel parti va
servir pour le civet et quel parti va
servir pour la terrine en effet très bon
nous allons à tourner tous arabes servez
tout va servir pour le civet mais nous
allons prélever dans un endroit où il y
aura de la chaîne des filets pour la
terrine
alors nous allons enlever les filets
tout de suite pour pouvoir couper le
reste après il faut juste pas grand
chose là juste des petits filets des
morceaux on va rendre ces cotes d'écouté
si vous voulez mener à tenir
ça va nous servir alors pour la marinade
pour la marinade
autrement dit pour le si vous l'osez
alors je me suis préparé une carotte que
j'ai épluché tout à l'heure pour faire
du tout de gagner du temps là on va
couper en morceaux ça sert à rien c'est
juste pour donner peu de roue et oui là
après nous allons y mettre de l'eau
niort nous allons couper en lamelles
aussi à l'envoyer la gemmi et la carotte
de l'oignon et de l'échalote dans une
borne marine arrive dans une bonne farce
il faut les deux delahaye comme et quand
un groupe comme ça aussi n'a pour ce
petit bocal y en assez haut mais de
laurier pas trop assez mais pas trop
parce que ça donne un goût très fort le
loyer il en faut quand même et finit là
après du termine bien sûr alors là on va
mettre des branches de thym autant magie
jonglerie s'éveillait la saison non
après on va mettre des clous de girofle
oui pas tellement là c'est tout des
baies de genièvre en pas beaucoup parce
que c'est amer mais il en faut quand
même une deux trois on les trouve
facilement les détenus et les baies de
genièvre et la noix de muscade râpée
[Musique]
je n'ai pas vu leur rap c'est trop lent
dans la série [ __ ] mais pas trop il en
faut et pas trop lourde et pourquoi
parce que le du vinaigre durci la viande
mais il en faut quand même un petit peu
pour dire tout petit peu d'acidité quand
même du sel du gros sel
les gros sel du poivre là c'est tout
pour un mari n'a pas donné de suite
après je voudrais du vin je vous dirai
pourquoi avoir ri et du verre on essaie
de mètres du bord un petit peu un peu
corsé parce que plus le verrait les
banques quand même et et la différence
et voilà voilà bien trempé et ont fait
mariner le tout 48 heures après pas
moins longtemps à l'avant prononça en
avance et on met de côté
voilà qu'à pendant 48 heures par la
terrine pour marquer ce qu'il nous faut
maintenant là on va préparer là on a
fait en a volé un petit peu nous avons
déjà marine et nos tranches de viande
marinée non on a un petit chez tricher
pour gagner un peu de temps alors ça va
aussi
voilà les branches oui mais mon travail
et on va les montrer comme damon aux
téléspectateurs
c'est tranche de l'ir pro c'est timo
ressources oui ça
genre des escalopes pour dire qu'ils ont
été prélevés à la limite de gigot jégo
j'ai quand même un bon demi centimètre
d'épaisseur pour qu'on ait le goût de la
viande un autre et puis à l'arrière
maïté bâle a pris soin bien entendu de
nous en mettre à mariner dans une voire
les nappes semblables et les ont pris
déjà une bonne couleur la couleur c'est
pas pareil voilà là alors maintenant
nous allons faire la farce une race erin
wasson en faire un petit achi je
commençais à la farce et je mets de
l'oignon de l'ail du gras de porc qu
voyez que je vais couper dans le gras du
port qu alors là il ya un peu d'oignons
du gras de porc le jeu h du japon et un
peu cheap ou de vendre ' roulait alors
c'est votre chance vous voulez qu'ils un
peu nous expliquer aussi si on peut dire
aujourd'hui mais non mais non c'est moi
j avais de dollars 6 assez roulé roulé
et de dames il ya du sel du poivre 1 et
voilà qu'on voit et de l'ail
alors elle a très bon goût et ça arrange
énormément ma sauce vous allez voir ça
et nous allons malaxer le tout avec doit
savait pas j'ai goûté c'est assez de sel
oui alors regardez c'est pas très bonne
qu'est ce qui manque c'est pas salé tout
à l'heure larsen gros sel du poivre du
poivre alors là on va y mettre un petit
peu de konya un peu de cognac pour avoir
la souche pense nouy aulas de l'armagnac
j'apprécie bien c'est pareil c'est pas
moi qu'il achète on va en mettre
ra continue à bien malaxer le too late
show crois que ça y est on à remettre
une couche de ce cycle on met bien plat
et là il faut regarder parce que c'est
tout neuf et alors là là j'ai fait un
truc
les sangliers que j'ai mis dans la
terrine voyez-vous les escalopes des
escalopes de sangliers que vous aviez
mis à plus de 24 heures à mariner plus
de 24 heures
je les ai passées à la fois qui se
trouve là bas dans de l'huile d'olive
nous supposons que six morceaux que
malines et vous laissez sécher et vous
les avez fait passer passer à la poigne
comme cela comme cela voilà alors je
vais bien les étals et là on voit
maintenant est alors en maintenant la
même opération
on va y mettre ne foie gras alors on va
couper des tranches la d entre nous on
va les mettre là qui est beau alors je
vais salez et poivrez
ces tranches de foie gras qui nous avait
pas de contrôle à 1
ça n'est pas vrai là oui je remarque que
vous le faites toujours assez aimée rose
noire il faut se relever la terrine oui
celle de l'autre côté et je vais placer
le foie gras une couche en abeille de
celle de ce côté argent et à mettre sur
nos morceaux de chair notre sens client
maître de gras au milieu cela qui va
faire les bordures nom et celui là qui
n'a pas eu de celle d'un autre côté là
nous allons finir de remplir avec la
farce à la dernière couche avec la farce
avec les doigts et vous
si vous sentiez ce que je peux sentir
pour le moment c'est effrayant se sont
tellement bon ce mélange marie nabeul
que je suis maintenant à finir de bardet
là tranquillement les petits croisillons
on en remettre du coup ça y est et nous
allons le recouvrir de papier
elle va en avoir ici ou l'aluminium mais
pas tout le temps de cuisson on va
dresser parce que là il faut que ça
qu'ils 1h15 tout simplement
alors on va mettre des papiers une
rigueur alors je reste par exemple 45
minutes avec le papier et le reste du
temps je sors le parti pour que ça dort
pas ce que ça resterait tout blanc ne
serait pas joli là est le feu un peu
sauf si vous mettez vos recettes
je vous attrape le bain ma mère marie
merci beaucoup s'est bien inversée palau
surtout dans ce maire marie a de l'eau
évidemment ça va nous espérons de tout
le monde s'est alors on met notre
terrine la voie là et nous permettant au
four thermostat 7 8 chaud il faut que ce
soit ça qui devient aussi qu'il faut
allumer son four bien est la cause donc
il faut les choses arrivent à bon quart
d'heure à mon quart d'heure à la voir
s'il faut qu'il soit très chaud là alors
nous allons le mettre à cuire et voilà
notre terrine terminée voulez-vous et
quant à des moules
attention maintenant directement facile
que là c'est comme ça que je joue
maintenant
non et on va retourner à l'eau
maintenant espérons que ce sera réussi
espérant voilà
et là il faudra laisser cahier d'écolier
à l'envers alors vers nous allons
attaquer le cif de civet alors voilà
notre viande que nous avons mis amériain
marine est tout à leur sert que nous
l'avons mis à marine ultérieure pour les
téléspectateurs
mais en fait nous supposons que la
marine et pendant 24 24 voilà 24 ou
d'héroïne qu'est ce que nous allons en
faire alors là nous allons sortir les
morceaux de la marinade
nous allons mettre du papier là dessus
nous allons échanger chaque morceau pour
les mettre à cuire
vous allez voir là nous allons les
étrangers viennent alors il faut pas
oublier que six morceaux nous avons
découpé dans ce que vous appelez le deux
ambitions de nos 25 juillet xavier en
particulier dans les côtes dans les
cotes les paul et paul davois l'ange est
alors bien les sécher
bien sécher pour le sécher un petit peu
nous allons les mettre dans ce récipient
nous allons prendre le chaudron il se
trouve là on va y mettre un peu de
graisse de canard d'abord et dans un
grincement pas que ça accroche un petit
peu plus de petites cuillères de la
grèce de cannes le canard gras et aurait
ça dans le feu avec notre cuissot de san
diego qui continue à se mijotait à ça on
va mettre la viande
sa faune cela reste un peu en retrait de
laisser les bien dorées et moi pendant
ce temps je vais me faire un rachid
oignons et d'échalotes que je vais
mettre cru nous y ont cru dans sur ma
viande pour parler aujourd'hui micheline
j'ai terminé de couper l'oignon
l'échalote et l'ail
je vais vous le mettre là rien sa
cuillère pour isoler alors on va mettre
tout ça ensemble à cuire l'a donc promu
et laissez pas vos relevés bien il faut
que ça donne un petit peu alors
maintenant on va mettre la farine
la première fait payer un petit peu là
cela va continuer d'évoluer par mettre
beaucoup et ça suffit notre dos il vous
fait tout ce que je veux dire c'est bien
mais j'aime ce cas vision là alors
maintenant on va mettre la marinade et à
la marina le vrai le jul et légumes est
ou non non non non non non non le juge
cela je vais retenir en feu résonnent
pouvoir mais nous on va faire un couloir
où 10 juillet l'artiste on l'avait
régnait une passoire que le pas soit il
faut combien de temps pendant une bonne
heure une bonne heure
oui et bien mérité pendant que ceux-ci
vécu bien tranquillement sur la braise
nous pourrions peut-être résumé ce que
nous avons fait bien sûr car nous avions
un sanglier tout entier nous rappeler
que l'on découpe et nous avons prélevé
cuissots un gigot ce gigot nous l'avons
entre l'ardèche pour que nous avons mais
je l'apprenne du couteau des petits
morceaux de
un boulot nous l'avons salé où l'on voit
vraiment la mort nous l'avons ont filé
tourne broche et nous l'avons fui devant
la braise à peu près dans un retard deux
ans de pause ou l'avare cuit devant la
presse vous devant votre temps résultat
magnifique il est au deuil pendant
qu'ils cuisent est une supposons que
nous avions préparé une marinade
l'avant-veille l'avant veille nous
avions mis les morceaux du devant celui
à mariner dedans nous les avons épongé
nous les avons mis à revenir dans le
chaudron où nous avions mis auparavant
fait fondre la graisse ça tous les ans
est bien dorée ensuite nous avons ajouté
de l'union pourrait fondre de lyon dans
le charlotte un peu derrière nous avons
saupoudrer de farine ou lier la sauce et
arroser avec le jus de la marinade à
marinade et cela il faut que ça cuisent
une première fois une heure l'idéal de
mer fois encore une heure après demain
encore un corner
et puis pendant tout ça cuit nous avons
fait une telle ânerie
alors pour la terrine nous avons prélevé
des filets des morceaux m on l'appelle
comme des tranches de gigot dans une
farce oui alors pour le détail je crois
que le mieux c'est que téléspectateurs
qui sont intéressés bri les demandes
roma ce que ce frère au longde dire
maintenant voilà c'est une très bonne
farce alors la prime terrine on a mis
des bardes là entre croiser les marques
sur le plat une couche de farce
une couche de ces lamelles deux
sangliers qu'on avait faire revenir
trois minutes dans une huile à la poêle
de vidéos livres une tranche de foie de
canard cru oui pas cuit sur leur mac upa
en conserve et puis ensuite on a
recouvert encore de farce papier alu et
une radio four une re quarts le dernier
quart d'heure on a l'impression d'avoir
été très elliptique ceux qui sont
intéressés qu'ils aient envie d'essayer
je crois qu'il faut qu'ils demandent les
recettes quant à nous et bien gibier à
poil et à plume verte erin bientôt un
prochain rendez vous maïté si vous
voulez bien
bien sûr à bientôt à bientôt